is easier to please
be real man be real who's easier to
please
you know the answer everyone knows the
answer everyone knows the answer I think
men are more simple yeah
and you knew that as soon as I asked
yeah you knew the answer so it's so with
that knowledge when we all understand
that women are probably more complicated
and complex and it's gonna be harder to
please her because a lot of times like
you lots opinions and feelings change
like the wind blows right like it's
gonna be a hard task to keep that person
happy majority of the time
are you trying though are you trying
that's the point if they're just like
literally leaving their marriage just
because they're just not happy that's
that's nonsense but if they're actually
trying to communicate it and the man is
just it's not getting anywhere then
there's a problem there that means this
woman is actually trying to communicate
how she feels and the reason you might
think women are hard to please is
because you men are so used to not
listening to women it's such a normal
thing to just say she's crazy everyone
listens to women what are you talking
about no you don't okay okay in our
current Society yes everyone does listen
to women no people don't listen to men
even men don't listen to other men what
you just heard what I said in certain
okay okay
in some areas of life men are completely
bought out of it so one thing about
where I'm what I'm studying I cannot
stand the hatred of white CIS men all
the time being the reason for everything
being terrible I feel like you guys get
a very bad rep and there's no
communication as everything is always
your guys's fault and that reductive uh
um view on life does not actually get us
anywhere so in that respect I agree with
you that men are not listened to at all
in a lot of areas to the point where I
feel like there's going to be no men
left in Academia other than like
engineering and Sciences there's no
nobody is going to be wanting to study
literature because what we're talking
about is it's just degrading them in a
way that is it's just terrible can I can
I go to one of your classes with you oh
my gosh
why do you think Society why do you
think Society she's not listening to men
the richest most successful in the world
are men the people
so it's a small percentage of men that
what percent of men are in those roles
yeah yeah that's like saying that might
like it's at least like 90 something
percent that are in that leadership role
you listen to a small percentage of men
okay
stop cutting me off I go okay what what
percent of men are in those leadership
positions what percent of men are in
those positions well in terms of ratio
and it's about 90 something percent no
no women no I'm saying what percent of
men out of 100 men you meet what percent
of men are in positions of power that's
not the point okay
just because you don't like the question
you have to answer the question what
percent of men out of 100 men what
percent of men are in those positions
but that's not the point no no answer
because she's trying to say what she's
trying to say that we don't know because
she when we say we don't listen by and
large it's saying we don't listen to men
as a whole there's a small percentage of
men that are in power yes and often
times
so okay come out of every 100 men you
meet on the street what percent of those
men are in Parliament
answer answer the question
if you don't want to answer the question
you can leave
a question you can leave it's not that
dude
it's not a personal question so you can
answer it okay we'll say the top 20.
okay you think two out of every 10 men
you meet two are in Parliament no not in
Parliament in power okay okay fine fine
we'll go with that so how how does 20 of
men represent men as a whole yeah but if
there's 90 something percent there's
more representation than for women so
when we're talking about listening the
people we are we seem to be listening to
oh man right but I'm saying they don't
want to start making decisions for
society it doesn't represent the average
man
we use this to make Envy of them and
this is why we're not listening to them
and this is this is why it's manifesting
in these terrible figures of Andrew Tay
and sneak on all these people are trying
to emulate this kind of masculinity
because they feel like they're not being
heard these are the only reasons why
these men exist and now we'll have women
being human trafficked and everybody's
now listening to women because we've
taken over the conversation I mean me
and Destiny we did a uh uh reaction
video earlier to Andrew Tate's
documentary and I asked Destiny like why
do you think so many guys like listen to
Andy Tate or resonate or you know follow
his his um lead and like you know it's a
lot of guys you know they're looking for
that leadership they're looking for
somebody like a father father figure
like a role model to to kind of you know
stand behind because they feel like
they're they're the guys they're the
demographic that is not being heard do
you get what I'm saying whereas like if
you look at current Society like it is
actually it's actually more geared for
women to be in positions of like you
know uh changing the the mindset of
people do you get what I'm saying no it
is
sort of the stats of people in power it
doesn't change no but listen those
people okay
you're right you're right all right
let's run with that yeah there's men
this is predominantly men that make the
laws legislation yeah yeah we're correct
yeah okay uh tell me one law that favors
men over over women right now
they don't need there doesn't need to be
a law
question bro answer the question just
please you can say whatever you want but
answer the question first okay okay okay
there's not a lot of laws that favors
men because they don't they don't need
to really come up with laws like that so
in terms of
um what's a law in terms of child
support right so a lot of the time a
woman is going to get the child and
she's going to get the child support
right why even though sometimes even
though even the society and Society men
seem to not want to take care of their
children because Society favors men so
there actually has to be things in place
rules in place to enforce it's
definitely not
um I feel Society has cast everything
masculine as toxic and that's why that's
not true even in this conversation when
they were taught she was talking about
how men like younger women they called
it ageist yeah and all I did was ask her
but why do we have to every time we make
a statement about men we have to say but
so are women
so we have to because no we have to talk
about women we can there are things that
women struggle with yes that's true but
we're talking about men's struggles
right now and it's like we always have
to put a butt women yeah because
women
it's like it's like Esther you you get
heard plenty oh I promise you you get
hurt
you
know
he invited me why
good teacher
but but the whole point is like why is
it every time we bring up a men's issue
we have to bring up women's
but if we bring up women's issues it's
not butt men we don't see that I think
the problem is because when these
communities exist it feels like none of
you guys can ever like talk about your
issues without constantly deriding the
other side like you yourself when you
did that big interview with I don't know
if it was the vice panel you said oh I
think women have it easier than men I do
yeah overall that's great okay that's
fine but the issue is that every time
these like sub-communities form they
seem to not ever be able to focus on
themselves they constantly have to throw
the other side of the bus too like there
are ways in life there are areas in life
where women absolutely have a use of the
bed you bring up things like the draft
right or expecting to stay home and work
whatever but there are other things
where men have as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible